i'm sitting here with jerry seinfeld
what in the world
is happening that i am on the conan
o'brien show
yes it's a crack in the comedy
space-time continuum
i used to own this network what's
happening
everything is back everything is
backwards yes i dismiss you now i'm here
hoping that you like me
desperately wanting to be liked well
it's working it's working very well
it is great to be here really is it's
been a long time i'm very happy that we
were able to do this
you know what's funny is a couple of
weeks ago i'm walking down the street
and i hear someone call my name
usually that's not a good sign i turn
around it's you
we have a very nice conversation and it
got me thinking you're just walking down
the street
yeah backpack and i thought what is it
like for you to walk through
manhattan it seemed to me like you're
that kind of guy that just walks around
well
you're kind of that guy too yeah you
walk around
yes but it was a very interesting moment
see now i know
i do walk i was being carried at the
time but
by two chippendales dancers those are
lovely guys by the way
huge chopper yeah
that's a favorite jerry what's up how's
it going this is lars this is
yeah i love when you see like for me
it's like i know
he thinks i'm some psycho on the street
i go hey conan
but as soon as he knows it's me he's
gonna change from oh no psycho
to guy i know yeah and it was very funny
to watch you
go oh you know you see that
that's how i'm with my wife every day oh
yeah it's like when you don't answer the
phone
you don't know who's there who is it
right right oh oh but but people are
there when people see you it's like you
come out of the television you're the
you know the so famous for being a new
yorker yeah
and you are the same i don't know people
think i come from some other dimension
you know
i'm like a parade float going down the
street i don't think it's the same
people don't connect me on a human level
it's like being
in a focus group all the time yeah
people are always telling you i didn't
like the zantac joke last night you know
you're always getting ratings on
everything you do doormen are just
yelling at me or cabbies they yell at me
and you know how you're doing they go i
like this i don't like that
right you know what i get i get people
telling me i saw the thing you did on
the show last night
then they explained to me why they were
up at 12 30. right
they say i love that thing doing the
show last night you see i take a
medication for a rash
at 12 30. all right now you have said uh
famously it's been quoted a lot that you
think new york city manhattan is good
for comedians it's good for comedy
what's the theory behind it irritation
is good for comedy
and everything in new york is irritating
yeah
i i have always right too
i used to do this thing about how i also
love the thing about when you're in new
york and you're the back of a cab
and you look through the glass it seems
like it's happening on tv
and whatever the guy does you think oh
well he's a cab driver i'm sure he knows
what he's doing
you don't think for yourself he's going
to kill me
it doesn't seem real and you trust you
see the license and you trust it
yes even though a lot of the letters are
like elements from another planet or
something
but you just trust in new york that cab
drivers know what they're doing but
it is very annoying that you put your
life in this person's hands that you
don't know you've never met them no they
know them they've never been here before
and
i'm sure he knows what he's doing right
right now you are
you've also said you think it's good to
be a cranky guy that comedians are all
cranky a little bit irritable do you
think that's really yes
yes you name it i can't stand it right
and that's where it all comes from i
don't like
things right everything
things irritate you everything irritates
me humans all inanimate matter
uh oxygen it all irritates all irritates
me yes yeah well
what a wonderful life you have this well
if you you know you try and make a joke
about it yeah yeah
i want to mention uh something else uh
you're also here uh to mention and it
deserves mentioning seinfeld the
complete
series box
of my life in that box right here and uh
phenomenally successful show and i
wanted to point out quickly a show
i think a lot of people don't know this
it's surprising people just accept when
something's a success and i think it was
always a success
seinfeld struggled i actually remembered
in the early years
yeah it struggled three and a half years
we were very borderline
people didn't at nbc were not excited
about the show when we did the pilot and
there was only one guy at nbc who really
did like the idea his name was
rick ludwig he was from the late night
and specials department and he's still
with nbc in fact he's here
tonight
his reward for saving seinfeld and
making it all happen is to stand and
monitor each one of our shows
but if it wasn't for him that would be
an empty box right now and uh
i deserves mentioning uh we struggled
too in the first uh well a little longer
than you probably uh and rick ludwin was
one of the people who stepped in and
said i think the show has potential and
uh
he was eventually proven wrong so thank
you rick
[Music]
you're batting 500. good for you uh
b-movie is in theaters now uh seinfeld
the complete series will be in stores on
tuesday i think everyone's going to want
to have that
big thrill for us thank you so much
seriously